hospitals have been repeatedly bombed in
what has been described as a systematic
campaign
to force the opposition to surrender
hundreds of airstrikes by syrian
government and russian warplanes
have been documented throughout the
years of conflict
many advocacy groups like physicians for
human rights
have tracked at least 595 air or
artillery attacks
on health care facilities in syria since
2011.
two years later they were described as
war crimes by u.n investigators
who said the hospitals were being bombed
to gain
military advantage but apart from
condemnations
little else was done and the rules of
war
continued to be ignored
the russian and syrian governments have
denied targeting civilians or civilian
buildings
despite evidence to the contrary and
international recognition of the
widespread and sometimes deliberate
nature
of the attacks the health sector has
been
decimated we know in northwest syria for
example the un has said that
50 percent of health facilities are no
longer functioning we know that 70
percent of health workers
have fled the country or been killed a
survey by the international rescue
committee showed
the risks health workers and civilians
faced in the past decade
81 percent said they had a co-worker or
patient injured
or killed 77 percent witnessed an
average of four attacks
on health care facilities eight percent
were
inside a health facility when it was
attacked
two of the hospitals i was working in
was hit
i survived but the feeling is hard to
describe
we all felt vulnerable we all knew the
risks of being in a hospital
it meant we could be killed
a decade of attacks has also compromised
the health care system
and its ability to respond to the needs
of millions of syrians
in opposition controlled areas in the
north and the effects of the coronavirus
pandemic are an added pressure
on an already weak system where there is
one doctor for every ten
thousand civilians the situation is not
good
there are millions of people in idlib in
the countryside of aleppo
no matter how much aid we get it's just
not enough
we really suffer from a lack of
medicines and medical equipment to treat
chronic diseases
a ceasefire appears to be largely
holding but it hasn't eased the
humanitarian crisis
the violence has caused critical damage
to syria's health
sector affecting the ability of millions
to receive
proper health care senator al jazeera
beirut